Good morning,
good afternoon and good evening ladies and gentlemen around the world.
Thank you for tuning in to the Tim Ferriss show.
This episode is going to touch a lot on creativity,
productivity,
creating an identity for yourself,
becoming a category of one.
And we will explain what that means,
but it's related to art and the art that is your life.
So let's start with two quotes.
The first is from Pablo Picasso and it is every child is an artist.
The problem is staying in artist when you grow up.
And secondly,
if you hear a voice within you,
say you cannot paint,
then by all means paint and that voice will be silenced to that as Vincent Van
Gogh.
Because most of you listening,
a lot of you listening will not identify or view yourselves as artists.
And perhaps after this podcast you will think differently.
But before we get to the guest and incredible guest,
a tip,
and this is a pro tip,
if you feel anxious,
if you have some type of low grade anxiety,
start making your bed.
I know this is a crazy recommendation.
It might sound ridiculous.
There is a gentleman named [inaudible] and he is a Hindu priest.
At one point I was having a tremendous amount of anxiety and he suggested start
making your bed.
At the very least when you then come back at the end of the day or even
throughout the day,
you will have that one piece of your life that you were able to control
completely and it will seem orderly.
It will seem as it should be.
So this sounds nuts,
but believe me,
the cascading effect can be pretty profound.
If you have anxiety,
at the very least,
perhaps you should consider start making your bed in the morning.
It doesn't have to be fancy.
It just has to look nice.
Okay,
moving on.
Our Guest Ladies and gentlemen is Mike Shinoda.
If you don't know that name,
Mike isn't musician record producer and an artist and he is perhaps best known
as the wrapper principle songwriter,
keyboardist,
rhythm guitars.
It's a long list and one of the two vocalists of the rock band,
Lincoln Park,
if you want to consider it rock band.
If you don't know Lincoln Park,
they've sold more than 60 million albums worldwide and have one,
two grammy awards.
Mike is also a solar wrapper,
if you would call it that in his side project for minor,
which I love to death.
It's amazing and the lyrics are incredible.
He's also provided artwork production and mixing for all of the projects that I
just mentioned and he has collaborated with everyone from Jay z to Depeche mode
and everyone in between.
It's a really incredible career.
The story of how he got started,
how they in some ways accidentally became the phenomenon that they are is
fascinating and there are many different takeaways we get into not just the
broad philosophical underpinnings but also advice for beginning musicians or
artists of any type parallels between music and publishing and and really any
type of creation along those lines.
A,
some of his daily rituals as well as for instance,
how he and his band rehearse how he song writes.
All of these things.
We really dig into it,
so I hope you enjoy it.
It's certainly visit the sites in the show notes and you can find all of those
including music for relief.org which is a nonprofit founded by Lincoln Park and
I've done work with them.
They've raised millions of dollars for survivors of multiple natural disasters
around the world.
You'll find all of these in the show notes.
If you want to see the transcript,
the show notes,
the links to all the resources that are mentioned,
the books and so on.
Go to four hour workweek.com forward slash podcast,
all spelled out,
four hour workweek.com forward slash podcast and this podcast is supported as
always by you guys.
So please,
if you enjoy the show,
if you'd like me to do more of these shows,
they take time.
They also take some money.
Please visit four hour workweek.com forward slash books,
four hour work,
week.com forward slash books where you will find the Tim Ferriss Book Club.
These are a handful of books that have had a huge impact on my life.
And uh,
if you click through it,
it'll take you to Amazon.
And that kicks back a little penny here or there to keep this thing going.
So without further ado,
I hope you enjoy and thank you for listening
at this attitude.
I can
start shaking.
You posted a question.
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
like snow to thanks for coming on the show.
Hey,
thanks for having me Tim.
It's been quite a few years since we first met and I was very amused to see on
your Wikipedia page that your bio shot is actually from blog world expo when we
first met and I guess 2008 or so through
through awesome.
I'm very glad that I was able to somehow indirectly contribute to your Wikipedia
page.
That's funny.
I didn't know that's where it was from.
That's amazing.
I think that actually is a,
is a um,
like a replacement of,
I had said to the fans at one point that I hated my,
the old page picture that was there.
I was like,
you guys,
seriously,
this is like the worst picture of me.
It was from like 2003 and I was in in mid sentence with my eyes half closed,
like somebody had put it up there as like to kind of mess with me I think.
And it was horrible.
And so I asked for,
I said,
somebody please like find a great picture and replace it.
That that's really funny.
So actually I'm going to put out a call to action to my fans right now.
I hate my Wikipedia photo.
It was taken of me and it's at an low web,
a speaking engagement in Paris when I had pulled an all nighter to get there and
just look like Al Pachino after a bender.
I mean I look really,
really rough,
but we were initially put in contact through Aaron red,
the Red Baron.
And so that's one,
just want to give him a nod and a thank you for that.
But I've been continually impressed as we've gotten to know each other about how
eclectic your skill set is and and how you've come to contribute not only to
your own work but to the work of so many other musicians and also done art
installations.
When somebody asks you if they've,
assuming they don't recognize you,
what you do,
how do you answer that question?
I usually lie first of all because if they don't know what I do,
then
I tend to like to keep things pretty mellow and especially,
you know,
I live in La and I live like on the border of,
I live near Beverly Hills,
but I think I'm technically in Beverly Hills,
but I'm not also,
so I tend to do like spend most of my time in more low key in the valley and
stuff like that.
Where in the Beverly Hill side you walk around,
if you see Paparazzi or you see somebody you recognize from people magazine,
that's not that surprising.
But if that happens on the valley side,
it's just a little bit more,
I think people get a little more attention.
So I tend to,
I tend to like stray away from that.
I did grow up however doing like the first probably my first love was actually
drawing and painting and,
and I had always thought I was going to grow up to do that.
Um,
in fact we started the band I started the band is like a hobby after high school
and I wasn't even very serious about it until midway through college.
And in college I was studying illustration at art center college of design.
It was very,
very serious school.
It's a very rigorous curriculum and a lot of the folks from there go on to be
really great.
You know designers in,
in auto and graphic design,
add film and of course illustration.
And you've done your own art installations.
I remember seeing a number of them.
There's one particular piece that maybe you can remind,
remind me of the name of,
there were two women,
there was a figure with a skull head and it seemed to be composed of dollar
signs.
Oh Man.
I did a whole series.
I'm not sure exactly which one that is,
but I did a whole series two parts show called glorious excess.
And it was about,
I was mostly inspired by the fact that I felt like I had a weird,
a unique perspective on the idea of being a celebrity.
We started our,
I mean I started the band as a hobby on the weekends with a friend of mine from
high school and we,
we never got into it with the intention of becoming a signed band or a popular
band or anything like that.
It was just like we love to do this where this is the kind of music that we want
to hear and nobody's really making the specific,
you know,
combination of elements and all of the things that followed,
followed.
And I found myself one day looking at it and going,
I'm realizing that,
you know,
it never really occurred to me.
There would be people who would like fabricate a whole,
I don't know,
music,
career with the intention of becoming famous or becoming like rich.
Cause that wasn't on my radar at all when we started.
We started it because love music and it seemed like,
yeah,
that's why you would start a band.
Right.
And then eventually your,
you know,
we're at the Grammy's were at the MTV awards and there are people who there who
clearly are there because they love to be famous.
They love to be celebrities and so on.
Even if they had gotten into it originally because they liked singing or
whatever,
but now they're clearly there for another reason and this art show as you were
going back to the art show,
I felt like I had,
I'm sitting there in the middle of that,
like literally just pulling out my phone and taking pictures and video and stuff
and seeing the stuff in first person and just simply not relating to it.
It's been a fascinating experience for me to look at different success stories
and try to deconstruct the motivations and also their focus on process or
outcome.
Right and like you said,
there's some people who are so focused on becoming famous or becoming rich and
of course it's very small percentage succeed at accomplishing that.
And if that's the motivation,
it would seem to me at least that they wouldn't actually enjoy the process of
creating the music or the books or the art or whatever it is that they choose as
medium.
And that's,
I always found it sort of a juxtaposition to your experience.
It seems like,
and I've heard the story,
you might be able to confirm or deny this,
that that u two the band started out and at least one of the members decided we
are going to be the biggest rock band in the world from from the very outset.
But it doesn't sound like that was or is the Lincoln Park Story.
What were the tipping points for you guys?
I mean as as the,
as the band came together over time and you met people not just in,
in high school,
but I guess you met at the,
when you were studying art.
Yeah,
that's right.
Well,
I mean it's a really interesting time to be talking about this kind of thing
because we just put out a new album called the hunting party and one of the
inspirations behind the hunting party was rock.
Right now is that a place where it's very indie,
all alt nd driven?
It's like everything is,
if you compare it to 10 years ago or 15 years ago,
it's very,
it's a lot softer.
It's a lot more dancy.
There's not a lot of edginess to it or aggression I feel.
And so there was a day when I was listening to the radio and I couldn't hear
anything or find anything,
they'll listen to you and I was listening to all my music,
you know,
services and I just had a hard time finding something that I w that that kind of
filled that void for me.
So again,
it's like whenever we have that feeling,
whenever I get that feeling,
that's usually a time when I go into the studio and I start making whatever it
is that I feel like I'm missing.
And that's what the new album is,
was inspired by.
But it's also what the first album and the original,
you know,
I'm kind of idea of the band was inspired by along the way I think.
And not a lot has changed.
We,
we've as far as like the,
the philosophy of,
of what we're striving for and it doesn't,
you know,
to your point,
it doesn't really include like being the biggest,
because if we want it to be like the biggest band in the universe,
I think we wouldn't make an album like our new one,
our new ones,
very aggressive,
very heavy.
We knew going it that we would be potentially hurting our chances at getting on.
For example,
getting on the radio and truth be told the radio is a great way to promote your
band and promote your album and so on.
So if you know,
going into it,
you're making something that's not going to be effective in promotion.
Like you're making a decision that is,
it's a creative decision,
not like for example,
a career oriented or,
or well maybe it is a career and his decision,
but it's not a money decision.
Right,
right.
So going back though,
I think there were definitely points when we were getting started.
We met,
we are,
we're all kind of friends from high school for the most part.
Um,
I knew Brad,
I've known Brad our guitars since we wrote like 13.
He was good friends with my best friend mark who was the original singer in our
band.
Brad's roommate was our,
became our bass player.
Dave,
my friend from college became our Dj Joe Rob,
our drummer,
came from neighboring high school and eventually mark are,
are are their singer part.
We parted ways because the,
the singing thing was just,
you know,
getting on stage like drove him creek.
It was getting like an ulcer.
He was so nervous to go on stage and,
and it turned out he was actually much more talented at like the behind the
scenes stuff.
He ended up managing bands.
He currently manages bands like Alice in chains and he managed Deftones tones
and Cypress Hill at one point.
So yeah,
he's,
so that was what he was kind of made for.
Once we parted ways of mark though,
we found Chester through a mutual friend.
And that was,
that was a moment where,
I only say that to say that.
So he came into the band,
we did a whole bunch more,
you know,
showcases and shows and tried to get signed and eventually got a little bit of
interest.
We got turned down by every label indie and major there was,
but eventually we worked our way into Warner brothers.
We kind of convinced them that we could like do almost like a demo deal and make
some stuff and if they liked that they continue on and we continue on with them.
Is it demo deal,
like a Spec deal where you basically yeah,
it's like a Spec kind of situation you may need,
let's put you in the studio and depending on how it's going,
it's a development thing.
It's something that they don't do a lot of anymore because they don't have the
budget.
I think like everything is so tight now because sales album sales are so much
smaller than they used to be.
They tend not to develop artists in this way anymore,
but with us,
to be honest,
there wasn't a lot of,
a ton of developing the do.
We kind of were developing on our own and in the midst of it because of a
complicated relationship of like the,
the guy that had signed us with his boss and that person with their boss and
they were all kind of new Chester,
our singer was kind of new.
So there's a lot of turmoil and they were trying to,
they started getting nervous.
They started imagining scenarios like,
well this spans popular in that band is popular.
And they tell us things like,
well,
you guys need a gimmick.
You need,
um,
we want to dress Joe in a lab coat and the cowboy hat and chest.
But you should like kick a shoe off at every,
every,
every show like stupid,
stupid record company stuff that almost sounds like something out of a movie
like spinal tap.
Right.
But it was absolutely true.
And in these were real suggestions,
like if you went back,
I imagine that you'd say them to somebody these days in the week.
Oh No,
I was totally joking.
I assure you they were not joking.
We were sitting in the room and they were literally ready to buy Joe a lab coat
and like beakers and put them in front of his turntables.
Um,
so yeah,
so,
so we got to that point and we were making the album and we were doing what we
wanted to do and got about halfway there and they tried to like run away with
the whole thing and change everything they wanted to,
you know,
basically kicked me out of the band.
They're talking to Chester and I telling him,
you're the star you need,
we need to do it this way.
And he's saying,
but this is like Mike span and he's like,
I've only been in the band for a few months.
What do you want me to do?
Like this is,
I think it's,
I think it's great.
And then we talk,
we all talked as a band and basically stood up to these guys and said,
you can either,
you know,
shelf us,
which effectively means they'd be putting us in record label limbo for the rest
of our career.
We'd never put out a record or they can just accept that this is who we are and
let us make the album we wanted to make.
That's a ballsy move I made.
It's it panned out,
but like you said,
it's the worst case scenario in that particular case isn't that they say no and
then you're able to walk off freely with everything that you had.
I'd imagine at that point,
like you said,
you ran the risk of being prevented from doing things elsewhere if you walked.
I don't know if he had any sort of contractual obligations at that point,
but it's been,
it's been very challenging for me working with a television over the last year
and producing episodes.
Having this division at Turner effectively get shut down and having the content
stuck in this limbo space where,
well you can't free it.
It's just kind of in a holding pen.
It's been super challenging it with when the record Lib will realize that they
had something,
it could be hot or that was becoming very hot.
What were the indications?
Did they take the music and present it to a test audience?
Did they hear it internally and simply decide as a group that they liked the
sound and therefore wanted to put some muscle behind it.
What were the indications that got them excited
at that time?
Especially that was our first album came out at a time when,
if we played a show,
we would put out a mailing list that at the merchandise table,
right,
we'd have a couple of,
we'd have a shirt,
our EDP and some stickers and we put out a mailing list.
If you like the band,
put it,
you know,
put your info down and we'll come back and we'll contact you.
Maybe we'll send you some stuff.
Maybe next time we play we'll contact you.
People didn't even have 50% of the people signed up with their snail mail
address because they didn't have email yet.
So as you can imagine,
like the MP three wasn't a problem for record labels yet.
We signed at a time when they were operating in a very old school manner and,
and it was,
you know,
so when our album rather our first single one step closer ever came out,
it was,
you know,
it's what like,
it's like a classic record label kind of attitude.
Like they throw it out there and see if it sticks.
And if they catch some,
you know,
some interest in it by the radio stations,
then they,
they go a little harder and they go a little harder.
It was that there's no testing per se.
They just kind of,
the only testing is like,
we'll put it,
you know,
see if we can get the djs and the programmers to put it on the air and then see
who's like,
what the response is and called whatever.
The other thing is though,
at meanwhile we were out touring really,
really hard playing maybe five shows a week,
sometimes six.
We were in an RV because we didn't,
we would've been in a van,
we didn't,
we could,
we didn't fit in a van because there's six of us with our gear.
We have a drum set.
And in Dj rig that was the size of a refrigerator.
So we couldn't fit all of our stuff in a,
in a van and I was driving probably more than half the time.
Um,
you know,
you get off stage like you played,
we may have played like 20 minutes,
get off stage,
clean up all of our stuff in a hurry,
put it all in the trailer and then draw.
I would be driving,
you know,
half the night to get to the next venue is pretty,
pretty rough.
But you know,
I know that we were boots on the ground like talking to fans in person and,
and you know,
managing our own,
the presentation of who we are,
the introduction,
like this is what our band is about.
We were doing that face to face.
So you were able to sort of refine not only how you communicate that defends,
but I would imagine that helps you think through a lot.
There was a really funny story.
When we first sign the label,
we told the guy that was representing us,
we told them,
hey,
you know,
can you get as many people as possible from who might be working on our stuff?
So mainly the rock department,
but whoever at the label wants to come,
we'd like to have a meeting at the,
at their,
you know,
in their building and introduce ourselves.
And he said,
yeah,
okay,
I'll set that up.
Keep in mind,
we were about 19 and we requested this meeting with whoever,
everybody from the label and they show up and they're roughly,
they're like between 25 and like 45 years old with like,
you know,
probably an average of 15 to 2015 years of experience in the music industry.
Okay.
And we go in,
you know,
looking the way we did and our first album me with probably like red hair and
Chester with the tattoos and piercings in his lip and whatever.
And we go in with an outline of what we are going to discuss with them.
Like they're going to come in and we're going to tell them how to do,
how to work our,
Ben,
let me just tell you what we're about.
Let me tell you how it goes with Lincoln Park,
the instruction,
the instruction manual.
It was so absurd.
I couldn't believe like in retrospect,
I can't believe they didn't just kick us out of the building.
I think that it was like humorous to some of them that this band had the balls
to just walk in and like tell them how to do their job.
And clearly we were way out of line.
But at the same time,
you know,
I think they admired the attitude of the group and by the way,
they knew that we were very sincere about this deep connection that we were
building with our,
with our fans from day one.
How do you think about putting yourself in the shoes of say a new musician now?
So you mentioned the,
the lab coat shenanigans and people trying to get,
trying to get you to adopt a shtick.
And I've dealt with a lot of large companies in a number of worlds.
When large groups of those folks try to have creative meetings,
they tend to sort of create a camel,
which is,
you know,
a horse designed by committee and it just ends up being ridiculous and a lot of,
I would imagine a lot of people succumb to that and allow things to change to
their band or their book or whatever that they really shouldn't to someone
coming up now,
sort of like the,
uh,
the actual rose getting off the bus and welcome to the jungle.
Right.
Someone who was very sincere about,
let's say their music,
but who wants to have a commercially viable career,
what would,
what would your advice to them be in this day and age?
I would say,
um,
for one thing,
you know,
there are a lot of similarities,
whether you're in,
in any creative medium,
whether you're an author or a filmmaker or a musician,
there are going to be situations that are not the obvious ones where somebody
comes in and literally wants to just like turn your thing into a,
you know,
commercial.
Obviously like,
like watered down commercial nightmare.
There's subtle,
it's,
it's really more about those,
those are easy to pinpoint and say,
okay,
that's absurd.
Like lab coat,
lab coat,
you know,
scientists.
Gimmick is absurd.
No Way.
Right?
But it's more about like,
I think it's more about the subtle ones,
you know,
because even if they're not trying to be manipulative,
a lot of times your partners,
their priorities and their,
their goals are not completely aligned with yours.
You know?
And that doesn't mean they're bad.
We had,
it's taken us a long time to learn that,
you know,
as a band because you know,
record labels had,
gets such a bad reputation as it is just being sleazy,
you know,
corrupt organizations and you know,
they to some degree they deserve that.
And to some degree they don't,
you know,
not everybody at a label is trying to scam all the artists and sometimes they're
doing what they genuinely think is best and they just don't,
it's not in line with what the artist thinks is best.
So that's,
those are the things to look out for because it can be very convincing and it
can be very subtle and it could not,
you know,
be a grade a mistake.
It could be like a minor level mistake that over time,
you know,
10 of those adds up to something catastrophic.
So for example,
in a situation like,
uh,
I think,
have we talked before about that with books where an editor like subtly you'll,
you'll be writing something,
an editor might subtly change a few
words and then another pass,
they subtly change a few more words and change and all of a sudden you're
looking at it and you might go back and compare it to the draft before they ever
got their hands on it and you go,
Whoa,
they completely changed the tone of my chapter or my story or what my point was.
And so on.
And it happens over time.
And at that point you've kind of committed to a thing.
So that's,
yeah.
And not,
not to digress too far,
but the,
he just brings to mind some of the lyrics from one of your fort minor songs,
which is,
you know,
only doing print interviews via email.
And that's not of course the,
the,
that's not verbatim,
but I'm paraphrasing,
right?
Cause the dealing with journalists,
it's,
it's amazing how just a single word replacement can change the entire tone.
It can take you from saying something that could be interpreted as profound to
completely absurd and stupid with,
with one replacement.
So,
yeah,
you really have to have a fine tuned.
Yes.
Context is everything.
I love to do print.
Uh,
I love to type my print interviews if it's possible.
Luckily these days I feel like with social media being as powerful,
it is as it is,
you know,
for you and I,
if we're in a situation where somebody prints something that they've edited or
changed substantially,
we can go out there to the fans and say,
hey,
you guys,
this was not correct and this is how it actually went down.
This is how I feel,
which has to happen once in a while.
But you know it's,
again,
it's like I don't feel like necessarily the people are being deceitful.
It's just realizing that like everybody's got their own agenda in different and
they have to a magazine
doing it,
but like I'm even a music magazine is not interviewing you because they love
music.
Right.
They that's not necessary.
That's not their,
their day to day is we need ad dollars.
We need click through like whatever it is that's going to get us that and if you
say,
if you have a 40 word sentence that chopped down to seven is really titillating
and interesting and we'll definitely make people click,
but it has nothing to do with anything you ever,
you said in your interview it's just clickbait.
They'll absolutely go for that because that's what they're,
that's what their business is built on.
Yeah.
It's important when I'm talking to people just getting ready or they're so they
have something taking off.
Usually it's a book coaching them on how to approach this stuff,
but on the creative side of things,
how has your songwriting process changed over time?
If it has and it was it different or is it different for say Lincoln Park versus
Fort Minor?
Well,
our,
our processes at the end of the day,
it's pretty democratic,
but it's rooted in an individual inspiration and craftsmanship.
So when a song starts,
usually I'm,
I usually start most of the songs it will,
sometimes it will be a very fleshed out,
better music.
Sometimes it'll just be a core progression on piano or guitar with some vocals
on it.
Those two
things are very different from one another.
Could you explain it just as a non musician?
I'd love to hear why those are so different.
So first of all,
just from the outside,
if you don't know anything about our recording music,
it bears mentioning that there's lots of ways to make music and a lot of
different genres.
I'd say first of all,
a lot of different genres have different approaches kind of built in that are
not similar to one another.
So for example,
a producer in Iraq for a rock band is a person that comes in.
The rock band is writing all of the music and the lyrics.
The producers kind of helping them make decisions and help sculpt the sound of
the album and they all work together,
but then,
but the musicians in the band are really making the song and the producers kind
of their coach in hip hop,
a producer does the whole track.
All of the music probably makes the hook.
The chorus makes basically everything except for the wrap versus the rapper
comes in and wraps on it and then the producer will make all the mixing and
finishing choices as well,
so they do a lot more in that genre.
Then Rock,
when we make an album,
it generally takes about nine months from start to finish to make the album.
In contrast,
when we were making this most when we're making the hunting party,
next door to us was a world renowned pop singers session and this person came
in,
their producers were there for a few days before they showed up and this person
showed up on day one and they were there for about 15 minutes.
On Day two,
they showed up for less than 15 minutes.
And on day three they neglected to show up at all.
And the song was actually done.
And I was talking to their people going like,
how is this even possible?
That all,
you know,
it was like,
we do this,
we do that.
And I'm just like,
this is crazy.
You know,
I,
I don't even as an art,
as a,
as a songwriter,
an artist,
like I've definitely relate more to the producers on that track,
then the person who sings it.
But I don't,
I don't even if I know if I'd be able to call myself an artist personally,
if I was the one just showing up for,
you know,
say 25 minutes and the song was done,
but also because that's,
you know,
my interest and my skill set and whatever.
That's what I love to do.
So with all that said,
you know,
I want to master as many versions of making a song as I can.
So every time we go into the studio,
I try different approaches.
I've tried approaches that come from,
you know,
folk riding and rock and pop and hip hop and whatever,
like whatever.
If it's something I haven't tried before.
That sounds interesting.
I might take that approach
and w with with say hiphop specifically and again I don't know any of these
people personally that you've collaborated with sate Jz and if I'm curious in
your particular approach,
but much like the sort of Youtube,
a story I've heard the Jay Z is very famous for improvising and at one point
just to appease some record executive pretended to be,
we're taking notes and it was actually improvising lyrics in the studio.
What is your approach with say hip hop specifically?
How much of your time is spent writing versus
improvising in the studio and what is your writing process look like?
So if it's on the shorter end of the song,
just kind of like let's say a song appears and it's just magically great and in
a matter of a couple of weeks it goes from the first notes played to something
that just sounds awesome.
Usually in those cases it's because the melody and the melody of the music and
the vocals have kind of arrived at the same time or similar time in a rap song
are my off of the fort minor album,
the song,
where'd you go?
Came up that way.
It was like I was playing the piano part,
I sang in the chorus.
I said that's,
that's what the song is.
I put a drum beat to it.
I wrote the lyrics to it and it was done.
It was really just a couple of weeks similarly on Lincoln Park Song called
breaking the habit.
That one was,
I had like a beat looping and then I was playing keyboard over it and um,
it was like a string thing and,
and I added some,
I was singing vocals over it and the whole chorus was there.
The melody of the verse was there and that was like within an hour.
I knew there was something to that song.
There are other songs that we've done where they take a lot of work.
I mean over the course of nine months they might,
you know,
come closer to sounding done and then B,
start to get boring or you know,
start to materialize and then fall apart once you add something.
There was a,
the new,
our newest,
uh,
we're about to put out a single called final masquerade and file masquerade as a
song that early on the chorus,
the Co,
the chords of the song,
like the Piano Chords of the song and the vocal.
We're there from an early point and,
and I,
and I knew listening to the chorus of the song and the,
and the progression and the verse,
that Song is going to be really good.
I really liked it.
At the time though,
we were deciding the arrangement of the song,
which means like what other,
what do the other instruments play,
what other instruments are on it?
And one of the main things that was a make or break element was the drum
pattern.
At the time when I wrote it,
there were no drums.
And so I kept,
I kept putting different things over.
I put programmed loops,
I'd write live loops.
I kept trying all these things on it faster and slower tempos and all this stuff
and it just,
every time I put something on and I could just tell it was kind of ruining the
song,
it just wasn't very good.
It was like a a,
B or a B plus.
And I knew the song had potential,
it'd be really great.
So it did take us a long time to just stumble upon the right thing.
And it was a time when I was in the studio with our drummer,
rob and I had already kind of picked the tempo and I had said,
what if we do like a halftime kind of almost like a more of a hip hop or classic
groc like Groove,
a drum loop type of thing.
And,
and um,
I don't remember what the reference points might have been or whatever,
but the main thing was that we just,
you know,
rob,
I said,
just play and as you play,
I'm going to like give you,
you know,
suggestions about where the hits might be or whatever.
And it immediately started coming together.
It was like within a few minutes you could tell this is,
um,
this is the best group for this song.
It's,
it's totally making the song better.
What activities outside of music have had the greatest positive impact on your
music?
They're not directly musically related and that's,
I'll leave that broad,
but I'm just,
any activities,
books,
inspirations?
Well,
you know,
I mean,
from our conversations that I love experimenting with new toys,
new technology.
Um,
I love reading.
I tend not to read a lot of fiction.
Um,
I've read your books.
I love books like the tipping point and blink,
et Cetera as well.
Um,
one book that I read that speaks to this,
the answer,
this question is a book called category of one by Joe Calloway.
And it's about,
you know,
finding ways to make what you do stand out.
Got It.
It's a really nice,
it's a really nice book.
Um,
there's a lot of great information in there and one of the things that he
stresses is,
is to benchmark what you do,
not against your immediate peers or your immediate competition,
even in your category,
but compare it to things that have nothing to do with your thing.
It doesn't,
if you're a a music maker,
there's no reason you shouldn't say,
well,
can I get great ideas from people who make cars,
people who make shoes,
people who make apps,
people who make,
you know,
cooking utensils,
whatever it may be.
There,
you could have a great idea based on something that's so foreign to your thing.
So with that said,
like I've been getting into things that really excite me,
but I don't know what,
how they might,
you know,
inform what I do.
It may be musical,
it may be kind of like the visual aspect of how we present our music.
But I love three printing.
And,
uh,
I most recently got into I fleet printing three d three d printing,
three d printing.
Um,
and I,
most recently my wife actually got me for our anniversary.
She got me,
um,
uh,
like a camera,
camera,
drone,
quad copter.
It's by Dji,
it's called a phantom vision plus.
And I've been playing with that lately and that one's actually really,
the,
the connection for me is just really easy.
It's like I love,
first of all it's just really relaxing to do.
But second,
I'm filming stuff with this drone and I filmed like our,
I'll film our rehearsals are all film stuff as we travel and stuff.
And that stuff is just really,
it's just fun to do.
You've constantly experimented with technology.
That's part of the reason that we bonded.
And I thought that blog World Expo be fun when we initially met.
One thing that is constantly on my mind is related to sort of routines and
habits of people who are highly effective.
And you are,
I guess right now as we speak,
getting ready to,
is it rehearsal record?
Oh,
we're rehearsing right now.
We,
we are,
um,
going out on a US tour with 30 seconds to Mars and Afi.
It's called the carnivores tour and we'll be out from August to September,
about six weeks.
Got It.
So as we speak,
it's about noon where you are,
what have you found for yourself?
What can you do to facilitate flow or sort of peak performance for yourself,
whether that's timing wise,
routines or rituals that you have.
What have you discovered personally?
One thing that I,
and I believe that by the way,
Kudos to you because one of the ideas from,
I think you're,
I think it was from the four hour workweek that occurred to me,
I don't know if it was because it was literally in the book or just the book
kind of inspired this thought.
Just in a broad sense,
looking at the things that you do every day that actually are making you better
or whatever that might mean and the things that you need versus the things you
don't really need.
That could be in your,
the way you handle your email is it could be the,
the things that you choose to read up on,
on your computer or iPad or whatever before you,
you know,
when you're not working your workflow during while you're working or even like
the things you choose to do when you're not.
Like,
is it making you the way you eat,
is that affecting how you feel during the day to do your work or your creative
stuff or have fun and all of that?
I mean,
I find that for myself personally,
I don't watch,
I barely watch any TV.
I watch almost no TV.
Um,
I do love movies.
I love going out to movies.
Um,
I find it a more like inspiring and rewarding experience than television for
some reason.
A lot of TV.
Um,
you know,
barring the like more series based stuff.
Like I love Netflix as well and I love like a house of cards for the same
reason.
I love going to films,
you know,
and I stay away from,
I'm not getting anything out of cooking shows and like singing competitions and
crap like that.
Like this,
especially the,
the reality shows like really I feel like I've totally wasted my time at the end
of watching one or two of those.
So that's like something for me that I just like I started just removing from
my,
my schedule.
Um,
what,
another thing that I always tell my wife that she's really,
she's really working on and I,
I think a lot of us have a tendency to like really want to respond to every
email and expect responses from every email and that's just unnecessary.
I feel everyone I work with,
all my friends know that given the opportunity to not respond to an email,
I will take it.
I will delete it at the answer is yes.
Cool.
I would sooner delete the email
if your answer is going to be yes.
Cool.
Yeah.
If it's going to be okay or I hear you or whatever.
Let's assume I got this email and we're good.
I don't,
unless I have something to say,
you know,
substance,
substance.
If it's substantive,
I will respond.
If it is substance,
I will usually spend it.
If I really feel like I have something
to offer,
my emails will be,
you know,
they tend to be a little longer,
they tend to have a lot of information in them.
Um,
so you'll either get no email or you're get something a little.
yeah,
but I,
I do that because I don't like to have like 150 emails in my inbox and I also
don't think like every time you send an email out,
I mean,
I've seen,
we've all seen threads where you've got five people on the,
on the email and all of them are responding.
Okay,
cool.
Yeah.
Great.
See you then.
It's like,
I don't want 15 emails saying,
okay,
cool.
Yeah,
it's stressful.
It's very stressful.
The uh,
the rehearsal itself that you're going to be going into,
what have you arrived at is your format for rehearsing?
What does that look like?
What's the template every band will be,
is every artist does is totally different when it comes to her saying,
I've heard that some groups just get together and they just jam and just play
whatever you guys as artists is the opposite.
We,
as you could probably imagine,
um,
we actually,
because we have six guys in the band and everybody's pretty much got,
you know,
families and other stuff going on.
We set up rehearsals in a way that you,
we start with just the most basic people who are needed on certain tracks.
So let's say we're right now,
we're practicing up two new songs for this upcoming tour that we've,
we haven't played in front of people before and we'll start those.
There were,
her first day of rehearsal would be with just maybe our guitarist and I and our
basis than our drummer might just be the four of us.
And then then we'll add Joe,
our Dj,
and then we'll add Chester.
There's no reason for chest to,
to come in and sing if the music's not tight.
Right.
So Chester gets a day or even two days off from rehearsal because of that.
It's,
it's rougher on,
you know,
especially like the instrumentalists,
it's more time.
But in the big picture it's all a wash because you know,
wild Chester isn't in here rehearsing on these days.
He's always,
he and I are always requested when it comes to interviews,
you know what I mean?
So,
so there's a balance,
a nice balance of things you and whenever somebody is not totally needed for
something,
we,
we kind of remove them from the situation.
And,
um,
also just,
uh,
just,
for,
for anybody,
for the techie people listening,
one of the things we do that to make those rehearsals extra focused,
we actually have everything tracked out,
all of the instrumentals from the studio recordings in the computer and we play,
we'll unmute anybody who's not there.
So if Chester's not hear,
his voice will actually still be coming through the speakers because it's coming
off the,
out of the computer.
So we use those strictly as practice tracks.
And then of course we don't use them live,
but we have those around so that we know,
you know,
and we can reference them to like,
oh,
hey,
you know,
Brad,
I think that this note,
this transition between the verse and the chorus,
it's actually these notes and we can listen to the album version.
Say,
Oh yeah,
that is what I played.
Um,
and then you know,
Mike is wrong or Mike is or whatever it may be.
Um,
and and yeah,
so that's,
that's actually a part of our,
not only our,
our,
the way we rehearsed but the way we just operate on stage as technology has
gotten as music performance technology has gotten more advanced,
it's actually allowed us to be a better live band.
That's cool.
Yeah,
exactly.
A worth technology can augment and not necessarily replace performances.
I think that's something that's often overlooked.
Just for my own personal curiosity,
what software do you use for that type of tracking?
We use a ton of different things on stage.
The main thing that I was talking about about like the performance stuff is in
Ableton live.
Ableton's great because you can actually let,
let's say if you imagine like in your iTunes library or whatever,
you've got to track and you can play it fast forward or rewind Ableton.
You actually can throw it in,
you can slow it down,
speed it up,
pitch it if you wanted to modulate the pitch,
you can mash it up with other things and so on.
So you know,
if we won some of the tracks,
like we have a song called guilty all the same and when we first started playing
it we wanted to practice it slower so that we could get tight and then move to
get it faster and faster.
So we actually just turn,
turn the tempo down a little bit in the computer,
played back slowly and and you know,
10 years ago this would have been impossible or it would have at least taken
hours for the computer to process that information and then you could do it.
Now you do it like on the fly,
right?
Instantaneous.
You can do it and in fact you could do it as you're playing if you wanted to hit
a certain spot and then slow down and you can do that.
You can loop spots.
You know if you want to practice one spot over and over.
We actually have a part during the set.
We do run some stuff,
some backing tracks when we play.
We try to be careful about that because we always want to be alive band first.
It's not a scenario where I think everybody when they hear stuff like that,
it's like you either wondering are their vocals and the track and whatever.
We try and stay away from all that.
Um,
generally it's like per cost of stuff and like be loops and things like that.
Again,
10 years ago if we were doing that,
if we were playing a song on stage and we had that running,
if you got off beat,
you'd be screwed.
If you wanted to extend apart,
you couldn't do it right.
Do you want to slow down?
You couldn't do it.
Now we can do all of those things on the fly.
If I walk,
if I decide,
hey,
let's get to this guitar Solo,
let's play,
let's have Brad played twice as long as that and played five times as long.
Any night of the week,
any show we can do that.
The Ableton rings a bell,
and I could be mistaken,
and I'll double check this for people in the show notes,
but I think that is also the software that IRA glass host of this American life
uses when he's doing live speeches because he wants to recreate the feeling of
one of his shows and so they'll have an iPad up and he'll actually call up
different types of quotes and so forth.
Very cool.
Yeah,
it's pretty,
it's pretty amazing stuff.
That's not the only thing we use.
I mean,
just so that it's clear,
like when I have a keyboard rig and I'm,
I'm mining software based,
I'm using a
bunch of stuff by native instruments,
I'm using stuff by other makers.
Joe Is actually running his completely off of a windows tablet,
believe it or not,
his real rig with a turntables and everything is actually the brain of that is
actually a windows tablet.
It's a surface.
Wow.
That's so cool.
I love it.
I tell you what,
I want to be cognizant of your time and I know you have to practice,
so I'd love to just do perhaps a couple of rapid fire questions if that works
for you.
And then I'll let you get to make an making your music.
So the first question is,
you mentioned movies.
What are some of your favorite movies of all time and that could include
documentaries,
non documentaries,
totally up to you.
I love,
I think growing up I was really into the like some darker stuff,
but usually kind of plot driven.
I always love the godfather movies.
I loved the usual suspects.
I loved fight club and seven.
Yeah.
Um,
I actually saw
club the other day and I haven't seen it in a number of years and it's still
still such a great,
like the story.
The writing is just so great.
Yeah.
And then on the other side,
like being in an illustrator,
I was into Annie Mae,
like I love to Kira.
Um,
I,
and I actually love a bunch of the Disney films.
Wally is awesome.
While.
I mean what an one thing that always struck me about that is it's like you've
got a movie that's more than half basically just score and visuals with no
dialogue.
Oh,
it's an incredible,
an incredible feat.
I've been researching screenplays recently and working on while myself and one
of the recommendations I heard was you should be able to turn off the sound and
follow the movie.
Of course,
Wally is a perfect example of that,
so even in a foreign film you should be able to follow the plot or a lot of the
major plot points.
Turning off the sound Pixars amazing with stories.
I'm actually hoping to have the president of Pixar on this podcast as well to
dig into the stories because I think it's so systematic and amazing how they
approach that.
Have you seen Ninja scroll before?
I used to be sewn in to just scroll.
Let's just say school is amazing.
Yeah,
actually.
And I think that our DJ Joe,
he's Joe has directed most of our videos and he actually just directed a movie
called Mall,
which is coming out soon on,
on,
I think paragon was the company that picked it up.
Um,
and he just debuted at this last week.
So it's coming pretty hopefully pretty soon.
Mau,
l?
No,
it's m.
A.
L.
Yeah.
It's about a bunch of suburban kids.
They're all kind of dysfunctional to some degree.
It's a very,
it's an indie film in every respect.
And it's,
these kids are very awkward all for different reasons.
And basically they're at the mall doing their thing and there's a,
there's another kid who comes in and opens fire in the mall and shooting people
and stuff.
So it's a really interesting,
you know,
uncomfortable and interesting film.
I had a lot of fun,
you know,
doing,
we did some score to it,
but actually going back to the Ninja scroll thing and all that,
Joe is Princess Mona Gnocchi,
Ninja Scroll.
Like he,
a lot of those types of movies,
those movies in particular have worked their way into some of his work in the
past.
Oh No,
come in fact,
in fact like Princess Mont and okay.
It was one of the,
one of the main inspirations behind our video for in the end.
Oh,
that's amazing.
I didn't know that.
Presentable.
And then they'll gay is for those people wondering,
you should watch every movie made by as [inaudible] Heiau or I guess an English.
Hi Ellen Miyazaki.
And if you ever go to Tokyo,
go to the Jubilee Museum,
which is the Ghibli studios museum in the middle of,
you know,
because she had a park,
which was just amazing.
Uh,
what is your favorite book or the book that you've given most as a gift to other
people
given most as a gift?
Wow.
I think when the tipping point came out,
I gave that book to a lot of people.
I know that category of one was another one that was really,
that I did pass around a lot when we're most of the guys in the band red blink
as well.
Yeah.
Some fascinating.
Especially,
it's the tipping point.
Really kind of put him on the map as an independent book writer.
And,
and I do talk about,
I do talk about four hour workweek up quite a bit,
Tim.
Well I appreciate that.
Thank you.
So thank you for that.
I would also feel remiss
if I didn't mention my wife's book by the way,
of course,
which is,
although I'm not a big fiction reader,
she wrote an amazing book called learning not to drown,
which is about a young girl whose brother is in and out of prison.
Um,
it was,
it was inspired by my wife's actual,
you know,
family growing up.
But it is fiction.
It's not a,
it's not a memoir.
It's about this girl who's brothers,
you know,
actions effectively like devour her entire,
social and family life.
And she's forced to make decisions about who she is and what she's going to do,
you know,
as she finishes high school and leaves the nest.
Did you,
did you read,
did she get onto,
you know,
she did.
And I read fiction before bed is a way of turning off my problem solving machine
in my head that tends to keep me awake.
So I'd recommend people check it out for sure.
And I'll link to that in the show notes as well as people grapes.
So can people get it,
can get a direct link.
When you hear the word successful,
who's the first person who comes to mind
successful?
Gosh,
I think of Rick Rubin for some reason.
I think that there's something about Rick that we've worked with Rick on a
number of,
of albums and he taught me a lot about songwriting and producing.
Um,
but also,
you know,
just life lessons.
He,
he grew up practicing transcendental meditation and although I haven't really,
I've,
I've went to this woman,
this teacher that he recommended and I tried it out a little bit and it's stuck
in,
it didn't stick.
Like some people do it every day.
I do not.
But Meditation and,
and just like focusing inward and turning off all the noise,
it's something I do believe in.
Like,
especially if you're,
that your tightly wound at any moment or in general,
you know,
it's a nice way to just get yourself focused.
And I feel like I make better decisions and I'm more effective definitely when
I'm,
I have a clear head and I'm fresher.
Yeah.
You know,
it's,
uh,
I don't think I've ever mentioned this before,
but Rick,
for those people that don't know incredible music producer,
you're going to look up his,
his discography on Wikipedia,
but first came across his name actually on the,
the notes inside a slayer album when I was just,
uh,
a little youngster.
But he's also for those people who,
who've seen the 99 problems video,
he's the guy with the big beard and the car.
Rick is actually one of two people responsible for getting me involved in
meditation regularly in the last few years.
Uh,
chase German,
Chase Jarvis,
a very,
uh,
you know,
worldclass photographer and Rick are both the people kind of responsible for
introing me to meditation and TM in particular.
Very cool.
If you could change one thing about yourself,
what would it be?
I guess the first thing that comes to mind,
something that I work on is not expecting other people to do things the way I
would do them.
Right.
Or you know,
not holding like my opinion and my way of doing things.
Even even like for you,
for you and I being people that try like spend a lot of time trying to be very
effective and,
and by the way ballot balancing that with things that we love to do as a part of
being well rounded and whatever.
And you know,
sometimes you hear things from other people and you go,
well,
why are they,
that's so stupid.
Why would they do it that way?
It's like so backwards and whatever and you feel like you want to tell them.
I mean it would get to be very preachy.
It's,
it's not,
I feel like my to do right by my friends and family and whatever that it's good
to just remember that everybody just kind of,
you know,
to give everybody room to do their own thing their own way.
And what I choose to do is,
is my decision.
Yeah,
for sure.
That's something that owns a hard one.
Right?
It's tough.
I still,
I still do that.
I find like if one of the things,
this is actually
funny,
one that my friends and I talk about is like,
first of all,
just like simple,
simple things like expecting people to work harder on stuff because I would
like,
that's,
that's not,
that's not very nice.
The other thing that's funny is spelling in emails when I guess,
like I said,
I'm gonna if I'm gonna write an email,
I'm going to probably,
unless it's like benign,
I'm going to write,
I'm going to like write it,
I'm going to edit it,
I'm going to look at it and there's spell check and all of this stuff.
And when I get emails where people are just clearly,
you know,
punching numbers on a phone and we're punching letters on a phone and it's,
it's a mess.
There's a part of my brain.
Maybe it's because my mom was a stenographer as there's part of me that my brain
that's just like,
Ugh,
like what an idiot.
And I like going,
no,
that's not nice.
Yeah,
it's so true.
It's a,
it's a real pet peeve of mine as well.
So to all those folks who were emailing people,
you want to get a response from,
take the time it,
because not everyone's sensitive to it,
but I'm very sensitive to it and I suppose that's just a byproduct of,
of writing and editing all the time.
But yeah,
I take the extra 10 seconds to look at anything that's under underlined as a
misspelling.
What is your most frequently played music right now on,
on your phone or otherwise?
Not In that,
that you haven't recorded yourself?
I don't want to send my stuff a lot,
Mike,
you know,
practicing something are trying to,
we have some activity that requires getting into our stuff.
I am listening to Simon.
There's two playlists I have and they're both actually in my,
I'm on Spotify and on beats under my name.
So if you want to check out some of the stuff I'm listening to you,
there's a lot more than this one batch of music that I'm listening a lot to is
some heavier rock stuff,
which,
you know,
Tim,
you're a fan of,
uh,
the,
there's not a lot I feel like right now,
you know,
this was part of the inspiration for our new album was that there is not a lot
of super exciting brand new cutting edge aggressive music out there.
And I do have a playlist of some stuff which includes a ban that Frank Turner,
who's like a folk singer,
did a hardcore band called Mongol horde,
which is amazing.
Such a good album.
Uh,
it's came out a few months ago.
there's band called doom writers.
There's a band called royal blood judging by the name.
You'd think these things are like really,
really heavy metal stuff and they're not.
There's,
there's a lot of melody and some of the songs and it's just,
you know,
really great,
energetic music.
Awesome.
All right,
last question.
If you could go back in time and give some advice to your 20 year old self,
what would it be?
20 year old self wholeness by Apple.
I don't know.
Um,
there's,
there's probably a bit,
aside from anything like cheat the system
to the future style.
There's definitely over the course of our,
I think it comes back to some,
one of the things that we talked about earlier,
which is just,
you know,
it's so important to stick with your gut.
If some voice inside you tells you that something is the right thing to do,
the right way to go about something or the right thing to make pay attention.
You know,
I've gotten to know Todd Wagner a little bit and he told me that when he's not
investing in a company or a group of people,
he always asks them to have the questions he always asks are,
would you be willing to quit your job for this idea and would you be willing to
put all of your own money behind this idea?
And those are questions designed to say like,
do you build really believe in yourself?
Do you believe in your thing enough?
Is this an idea for you or is this an idea because you think someone else will
like it and if you believe in it to the point where you put yourself on the
line,
then that's a good measure of how important it is to you and how much you
believe in it.
Definitely.
It's so true.
I mean,
just for those people listening in,
at least for me also,
if,
if you scratch your own itch and create something for yourself,
the thing that you've been looking for it,
you'll always have an audience of one.
And that's more than I can say for a lot of folks who kind of focus on the
outcome and uh,
and miss that because you'll have to live with whatever you put out.
If you put something out.
Mike,
this is,
this has been a blast.
Where can people find out more about you,
what you're up to and so on?
I'm looking,
park is obviously on Lincoln park.com it's l,
I N K I n p a R k.com.
Any social media,
Instagram,
Facebook,
Twitter,
whatever we are,
we are available under the same name.
I am,
uh,
Mike shinoda.com and you can find me under that name on Instagram,
Twitter,
and Facebook as well.
Beautiful.
Mike,
I'll let you get to your music,
but uh,
keep putting out great stuff and look forward to hanging against soon.
Hopefully next time I'm in a down south and La.
Yeah,
thanks man.
Cool.
Awesome.
Thanks buddy.
I'll let you get to it.
I really appreciate it.
You want more of the Tim Ferriss show?
You can subscribe to the podcast on iTunes or go to for our blog.com f l o g.com
where you'll find an award winning blog,
tons of audio and video interview stories with people like Warren Buffett and
Mike Shinoda from Linkin Park,
the books plus much,
much more.
Follow Tim on twitter@twitter.com slash t Ferris.
That's t I f e R R,
I s s or on Facebook at facebook.com/tim Ferris.
Until next time,
thanks for listening.